yeah I wanted to continue this
conversation about anonymous giving
versus having big names attached to the
nation's we recently read a book called
random slaughter where the author argued
based on the philosophy of my mom and
he's saying that anonymous giving is
actually perhaps the most noble form of
giving the best form of giving but
obviously we're an institution that's
marked with names as carl touched upon
earlier so how do you reconcile these
two perspectives does yell value
anonymous donations in a different way
than these big name donations and do you
engage with these different types of
donors differently well you know Yale
values you know anonymous gifts and
gifts that are named in the same way
because it's a gift and it's given in
the spirit to help the university I say
to me it's a personal choice what a
donor should do if he or she feels
comfortable having the name on it I
think it is good because it reminds
others that you know this did not grow
on trees you know this did not come from
nowhere people actually took
responsibility to to nurture this place
and give it the resources so that you
could become what it is but at the same
time you know an anonymous gift can have
the same impact I just would not be
completely comfortable with only
anonymous giving because it just would
raise in my view questions and should
raise questions with others about
transparency and you know what is the
financial situation